the best rule to use when criticism  springs to your mind is to wait wait a  while and try to look for the reasons  behind the act you would criticize it's  also a good time to ask oneself who am i  to be criticizing others am i really all  that great and pure and all-knowing and  perfect by all means wait until the heat  of anger is dissipated this is one of  the worst most difficult things to do  and it takes a very mature person to  master their wisdom and self-control to  withhold criticism but it's the way to  greatness and one of the best-known ways  to earn the respect and or love of  others  people know when they've done something  wrong or foolish and they usually know  that you know it too and when you  refrain from being critical they're  grateful they respect you often as not  they'll be much tougher on themselves  and make a concerted effort to avoid  making the same mistake again